- ברוכים השבים ל"הבנת מידע קוונטי
וחישוב." שמי John Watrous, ואני המנהל הטכני
של IBM Quantum Education.
זה השיעור החמישי בסדרה, וזה השיעור הראשון
ביחידה השנייה של הסדרה, שעוסקת באלגוריתמים קוונטיים.
ביחידה הזאת, נחקור
יתרונות חישוביים של מידע קוונטי, כלומר, נסתכל
על מה שאפשר לעשות
עם מחשבים קוונטיים והיתרונות שמחשבים קוונטיים עשויים פוטנציאלית להציע
על פני מחשבים קלאסיים.
אנחנו נתמקד במה שאפשר לעשות עם מחשב קוונטי בודד בניגוד להגדרה מבוזרת,
למשל,
שבה מספר מחשבים קוונטיים מתקשרים דרך רשת כלשהי.
יש, למעשה, יתרונות קוונטיים שאפשר למצוא בהגדרות מבוזרות, שבהן תקשורת
וקריפטוגרפיה נכנסות לתמונה,
אבל אנחנו לא הולכים
לדבר על הדברים האלה ביחידה הזאת.
היחידה הזאת עוסקת באלגוריתמים קוונטיים שרצים על מחשבים קוונטיים בודדים.
בואו נתחיל עם שאלה טבעית. אילו יתרונות מחשב
קוונטי עשוי פוטנציאלית להציע?
העיקרי הוא שמחשבים קוונטיים עשויים לספק פתרונות מהירים יותר לכמה בעיות חישוביות.
זמן הוא יקר, ולמרות שהמחשבים שאנחנו
משתמשים בהם כל יום הם די מהירים, הם עדיין איטיים מדי
כדי לפתור בעיות חישוביות מסוימות בגלל הקושי
החישובי המובנה של הבעיות האלה.
הפוטנציאל הזה שמחשבים קוונטיים עשויים לאפשר לנו לפתור בעיות שמחשבים קלאסיים
איטיים מדי כדי לפתור
הוא באמת מה שהניע
את המחקר באלגוריתמים קוונטיים בעשורים האחרונים.
יש משאבים חישוביים
נוספים מלבד זמן שאפשר לשקול, כמו כמות זיכרון המחשב הדרושה לחישובים,
אבל מחשבים קוונטיים לא יכולים
להציע יותר מדי חיסכון מבחינת זיכרון, כפי שמתברר, וזיכרון מחשב קלאסי
הוא די זול
במיוחד בהשוואה לזיכרון קוונטי. אז פשוט אין
הרבה הבטחה כאן.
אפשר גם לחשוב על משאבים אחרים כמו כמות האנרגיה
הדרושה לחישוב, אבל בעצם לא
צריך הרבה אנרגיה בכלל
כדי לחשב קלאסית, במיוחד אם אתם
מוכנים להאט דברים.
אז זה באמת הזמן
הנדרש לחישובים, זה המוקד העיקרי שלנו.
הנה סקירה כללית של השיעור, שעוסק במודל
חישובי ספציפי שנקרא מודל השאילתות.
אפשר לחשוב על המודל הזה כמעין צלחת פטרי לפיתוח רעיונות אלגוריתמיים, קוונטיים וקלאסיים כאחד.
הוא לא נועד להיות מודל מעשי שמתאר את סוגי
הבעיות החישוביות שאנחנו נתקלים בהן בחיים האמיתיים.
נתרחק ממודל השאילתות בשיעורים הבאים של היחידה הזאת ונתמקד במקום במודלים שמונעים על ידי תפיסות מעשיות יותר
של חישוב,
אבל מודל השאילתות הוא
מקום טוב מאוד להתחיל.
זה מודל פשוט שמאפשר לנו לחקור את
הפוטנציאל של מחשבים קוונטיים בלי הרבה פרטים
טכניים שמפריעים,
והוא גם מאפשר לנו לבודד כמה מהרעיונות
החשובים באמת מאחורי חישוב קוונטי ואיך הוא עובד.
חישוב קוונטי, למעשה, התפתח בהתחלה בתוך המודל הזה, והרעיונות שפותחו
בתוכו השפיעו ישירות מאוד על
אלגוריתמים קוונטיים חשובים
כמו האלגוריתם של Shor לפירוק לגורמים.
בחלק הראשון של השיעור, נסתכל על מה בדיוק מודל השאילתות של חישוב הוא,
ובחלקים השני, השלישי,
והרביעי, נדון בשלושה
אלגוריתמי שאילתות קוונטיים, כלומר האלגוריתם של Deutsch,
האלגוריתם של Deutsch-Jozsa,
והאלגוריתם של Simon, שחושפים יתרונות
מרשימים יותר ויותר
של מחשבים קוונטיים
על פני מחשבים קלאסיים במודל השאילתות של חישוב.
כדי להסביר את מודל השאילתות של חישוב, בואו נתחיל קודם עם הפשטה
יותר סטנדרטית של חישוב.
הנה תמונה שמייצגת
חישוב במונחים פשוטים ובסיסיים מאוד.
יש לנו קלט, שבדרך כלל לוקח את
הצורה של מחרוזת בינארית, למרות שאפשר להשתמש בסמלים
אחרים אם נרצה.
הקלט מסופק לחישוב, שמיוצג על ידי מלבן
כחול בתמונה הזאת,
והתוצאה של החישוב היא שנוצר פלט כלשהו, ושוב, זה בדרך כלל
מחרוזת בינארית.
כמובן, התמונה הזאת
לא ספציפית בכלל לגבי איך החישוב עצמו עובד.
אפשר לנסח מודלים
חישוביים ספציפיים שונים כדי לעשות את זה, כמו מכונות טיורינג
ומעגלים בוליאניים,
או מעגלים קוונטיים אם אנחנו חושבים על
חישוב קוונטי.
זה נכון שהתמונה הזאת
לא מייצגת את העובדה שהרבה מהמחשבים
שאנחנו משתמשים בהם כל יום מקבלים ברציפות
קלט ומייצרים פלט,
בעצם מתקשרים איתנו ועם מחשבים אחרים דרך
האינטרנט, למשל.
אבל אנחנו לא מנסים לייצג
את האינטראקציות האלה כאן.
זה על מידול
משימות חישוביות מבודדות.
למשל, הקלט יכול להיות
הקידוד הבינארי של מספר או ייצוג של מטריצה
או תיאור של מולקולה או באמת כל דבר אחר שיש לנו בראש, ויש איזושהי משימה חישובית
שמתבצעת על הקלט הזה לבד.
הנקודה המרכזית כאן היא
שכל הקלט מסופק לחישוב, ושום דבר לגבי
הקלט לא מוסתר ממנו.
מודל השאילתות של
חישוב עובד אחרת.
במודל השאילתות, הקלט זמין
בצורה של פונקציה שהחישוב יכול
לגשת אליה על ידי ביצוע שאילתות,
או במילים אחרות, על ידי הערכת הפונקציה
על קלטים שונים.
כאן אתם יכולים לראות את זה מיוצג
בצורת תמונה.
בדומה למה שהיה לנו קודם, החישוב מיוצג
על ידי מלבן כחול, אבל במקום לקבל קלט ישירות
בצורת מחרוזת
של ביטים, למשל, הוא ניגש לקלט על ידי שאילת שאלות בפועל
וקבלת תשובות.
לפעמים אנחנו משתמשים
במונחים אורקל וקופסה שחורה כדי להתייחס למנגנון
שמספק את הקלט.
יש הבחנה בין
אורקל לקופסה שחורה בתורת הסיבוכיות, אבל זה לא יהיה רלוונטי בכלל לצרכי הדיון הזה.
בכל מקרה, המונחים האלה נועדו
להעביר את הרעיון הבסיסי.
ביוון העתיקה, אפשר
היה ללכת לאורקל, כמו האורקל בדלפי,
ולשאול שאלה חשובה,
והאורקל היה עונה
על השאלה הספציפית הזאת, אבל היא בהחלט לא הייתה מספרת לך את כל מה שהיא ידעה.
בקווים דומים, כשאנחנו
חושבים על קופסה שחורה, יש לנו בראש איזשהו
תהליך או מערכת
שבהם אנחנו יכולים לבחור מה נכנס ואנחנו יכולים לראות מה יוצא, אבל אין לנו שום הבנה
של הפעולה הפנימית שלה.
וזה המצב כאן. הקלט לבעיה
לוקח את הצורה של פונקציה, וכל מה שאנחנו יכולים לעשות זה
להעריך את הפונקציה הזאת,
אבל מעבר לזה, אין לנו
שום ידע או הבנה איך היא עובדת.
לאורך כל השיעור,
נשמור את האות f לפונקציה שמייצגת
את הקלט, ונניח
שהיא תמיד לוקחת את
הצורה שאתם רואים ממש כאן.
סיגמא מסמנת את האלפבית הבינארי, אז f היא פונקציה ממחרוזות
של ביטים למחרוזות של ביטים,
ובאופן ספציפי, נניח
שהקלט ל-f הוא מחרוזת של ביטים באורך n, והפלט הוא מחרוזת
של ביטים באורך m,
כאשר n ו-m הם מספרים שלמים חיוביים.
לבעיות שונות, יהיו
לנו הגבלות על n ו-m, אבל בכל המקרים, פונקציית הקלט
תיקח צורה כזאת.
כשאנחנו אומרים שחישוב
עושה שאילתה, מה שאנחנו מתכוונים הוא שהפונקציה
f מוערכת פעם אחת,
כלומר, איזושהי מחרוזת x באורך N נבחרת על ידי החישוב, והמחרוזת f של x
הופכת זמינה עבורו
על ידי האורקל או הקופסה השחורה. ולבסוף, הדרך הפשוטה מאוד שבה נמדוד את העלות החישובית
של אלגוריתם שאילתות היא לספור כמה שאילתות הוא דורש.
אז, למרות שזה נכון שאנחנו
באמת הכי מעוניינים בכמה זמן חישובים לוקחים, כשאנחנו חוקרים את מודל השאילתות,
בדרך כלל אנחנו שומרים
על דברים פשוטים ופשוט סופרים שאילתות, וזה מה שנעשה בשיעור הזה.
עכשיו, בואו נסתכל על
כמה דוגמאות של בעיות שאילתות, כלומר בעיות
חישוביות במודל השאילתות,
וכאן, דרך אגב, אני רק הולך לתאר
את הבעיות עצמן, ובשלב הזה, לא אגיד שום דבר
על איך לפתור אותן.
הבעיה הראשונה היא בעיית ה-OR.
במקרה הזה, הקלט הוא פונקציה
מ-n ביטים לביט אחד בלבד, אז m שווה ל-1 בבעיה הזאת,
והפלט הנדרש עבור
הבעיה הוא 1 או 0.
אם יש איזושהי מחרוזת של n ביטים x שעבורה f של x שווה ל-1, אז התשובה הנכונה היא 1,
ואחרת, אם f של x הוא
תמיד 0 לכל מחרוזת x, אז התשובה הנכונה היא 0.
אז אם אנחנו חושבים על הפונקציה f כמספקת לנו גישה אקראית
ל-2 בחזקת n ביטים, אחד לכל מחרוזת של n ביטים x,
אז מה שמבקשים
זה את ה-OR של הביטים האלה, ולכן זה נקרא בעיית ה-OR.
דוגמה נוספת היא בעיית הזוגיות, שדומה לבעיית ה-OR חוץ מזה שהיא מבקשת את הזוגיות,
או במילים אחרות, את ה-eXclusive OR של כל ערכי
הפלט של ביט יחיד של הפונקציה.
דרך אחרת לומר את זה היא
שהתשובה הנכונה היא 0 אם מספר מחרוזות ה-n ביטים x שעבורן f של x שווה ל-1 הוא זוגי,
והתשובה הנכונה היא
1 אם המספר הזה הוא אי-זוגי.
דוגמה לבעיה שבה m לא בהכרח שווה ל-1 היא בעיית המינימום.
כאן, הפונקציה f לוקחת את הצורה הרגילה, ואין הגבלות על n ו-m,
והתשובה הנכונה היא כל ערך פלט
של הפונקציה שמופיע ראשון בסדר הלקסיקוגרפי
או סדר המילון
של מחרוזות בינאריות. לחילופין, אם אתם רוצים
לחשוב על מחרוזות באורך m כמייצגות מספרים שלמים
לא-שליליים בייצוג בינארי,
אז התשובה הנכונה
היא הערך הקטן ביותר האפשרי או המינימלי שיוצא
מהפונקציה הזאת.
לפעמים אנחנו גם שוקלים בעיות שאילתות שבהן יש לנו הבטחה
על פונקציית הקלט, או במילים אחרות, איזשהו
סוג של ערבות עליה,
ואנחנו לא דואגים לגבי פונקציות שלא עומדות בהבטחה הזאת.
פונקציות שלא מקיימות את ההבטחה נחשבות כקלטים של "לא אכפת".
ואנחנו פשוט לא אחראים למה שקורה על הקלטים האלה.
הנה דוגמה לבעיית שאילתות עם הבטחה שנקראת חיפוש ייחודי.
היא קשורה לבעיית
ה-OR, אבל היא שונה.
לפונקציית הקלט יש את אותה
צורה כמו בבעיית ה-OR, כלומר שהיא לוקחת
מחרוזות של n ביטים לביטים.
הפעם, מובטח לנו שיש
בדיוק מחרוזת אחת Z שגורמת ל-f להיות שווה ל-1,
כאשר f של x שווה ל-0
לכל מחרוזת x מלבד z, והפלט הנכון
הוא המחרוזת הייחודית z הזאת.
כמובן, יש
בחירות עבור הפונקציה f שלא מקיימות את התנאי הזה, אבל אנחנו לא מציבים שום דרישות בכלל
על אלגוריתמים לבעיה הזאת כשהם מקבלים פונקציות
כאלה כקלט.
אנחנו מתעניינים רק בפונקציות שכן מקיימות את ההבטחה.
עכשיו, כל ארבע
הבעיות שהזכרתי הן בעיות די טבעיות, כלומר שקל להסביר אותן,
וקל לדמיין מצבים שבהם צורך לפתור אותן עשוי לעלות, אבל כמה בעיות שאילתות
הן לא ככה בכלל.
למעשה, לפעמים, אנחנו שוקלים בעיות שאילתות
מאולצות מאוד, שבהן קשה לדמיין שמישהו אי פעם
באמת ירצה לפתור אותן.
הבעיה של Simon, שנראה
מאוחר יותר בשיעור, בערך נופלת לקטגוריה הזאת, אבל יש כמה אחרות
שהן הרבה יותר גרועות במובן מסוים, אבל הן, בכל זאת, מתגלות כדי חשובות לחקירת מודל השאילתות.
אנחנו לא חוקרים את הבעיות האלה כי אנחנו בהכרח רוצים
לפתור אותן בפרקטיקה.
הדרך שאפשר לחשוב על זה היא שאנחנו מחפשים
קיצוניות מסוגים שונים,
בפרט, כשאנחנו עובדים בתוך
צלחת הפטרי של המודל הזה, דרך טבעית לחקור
רעיונות אלגוריתמיים קוונטיים
היא לנסח בעיות מאולצות מאוד, שבהן אפשר לנצל בצורה הטובה ביותר את
הכוח של מחשבים קוונטיים.
וזה יכול בעצם
לשפוך הרבה אור על איך מחשבים קוונטיים
יכולים להיות שימושיים פוטנציאלית בהגדרות מעשיות יותר.
אפשר לפרמל את המושג
של שאילתה בדרכים שונות בהתאם לאיזה מודל
חישובי אנחנו עובדים.
למשל, במודל מכונת
הטיורינג של חישוב, שלא דיברנו עליו ולא ניכנס אליו בסדרה הזאת,
יש דרך מסוימת
לפרמל את המושג של שאילתה שהגיונית למודל הזה.
למודלים של מעגלים, אנחנו מגדירים סוגים מיוחדים של
gate שנקראים query gates, וככה שאילתות
מיוצגות באופן פורמלי.
למעגלים בוליאניים, יש דרך פשוטה מאוד לעשות את זה, שהיא פשוט לדמיין
שיש לנו query gates
שמעריכים את פונקציית הקלט ישירות, כמו שאתם יכולים לראות כאן על המסך.
הרעיון הוא שאפשר
להשתמש ב-query gates האלה כדי לבנות מעגלים שפותרים כל
בעיה שאנחנו מסתכלים עליה,
וכדי לעבוד נכון, המעגלים צריכים לתת את התשובה הנכונה לכל פונקציית קלט f שניתנת,
בהנחה שהיא עומדת בהבטחה במקרה של בעיית הבטחה.
הנה דוגמה פשוטה
של מעגל בוליאני שפותר את בעיית הזוגיות
כאשר n שווה ל-1,
אז פונקציית הקלט f היא מביט
אחד לביט אחד במקרה הזה.
מה שהמעגל הזה עושה הוא להעריך את הפונקציה
f על הקלטים 0 ו-1 באמצעות שני ה-query gates האלה.
לאחר מכן הוא מכניס את שני ערכי הפלט שהוא
מקבל מה-query gates למעגל הבוליאני מהשיעור השלישי שמחשב את ה-XOR,
שזה אותו דבר כמו הזוגיות.
כדי להבהיר, שני ערכי
הקלט האלה ממש כאן הם לא קלטים לבעיה,
כלומר בעיית הזוגיות,
כשאנחנו עובדים עם מודל השאילתות, הקלט לבעיה
הוא הפונקציה f, ואתם צריכים לחשוב על שני
הקלטים האלה למעגל
כערכים מקודדים מראש
שלעולם לא משתנים, הם בעצם חלק מהאלגוריתם.
אנחנו רוצים לחשב את ה-XOR של f 0 ו-f 1, אז אתחלנו את שני
החוטים האלה בדרך הזאת
כדי שזה יעבוד. השתמשנו בשני query gates
כאן, הזה והזה,
ולכן האלגוריתם שמיוצג
על ידי המעגל הבוליאני הזה עושה שתי שאילתות, ואם אנחנו חושבים על בעיית
הזוגיות לרגע
לפונקציות מביט אחד לביט אחד, אנחנו רואים שזה הכרחי לחלוטין לכל מעגל בוליאני
שפותר את הבעיה הזאת
לעשות לפחות שתי שאילתות.
אם אתם עושים רק שאילתה אחת כך שאתם יודעים רק ערך פלט אחד
של הפונקציה f ולא את השני, אין לכם בעצם
שום מידע בכלל
על הזוגיות, כי ערך הפלט השני
יכול באותה מידה להיות 0 או 1, מה שמוביל לכל אחד משני
הפתרונות האפשריים
לבעיה. אז מבחינת מספר
השאילתות שהוא עושה, המעגל הבוליאני הזה הוא הטוב ביותר שאפשר
לבעיית הזוגיות
כאשר n שווה ל-1.
יש עוד נקודה אחת לגבי query gates שכדאי להזכיר לפני שנמשיך, והיא שכשאנחנו מתכננים ומנתחים אלגוריתמי שאילתות,
אנחנו לא דואגים בכלל לגבי איך
query gates ממומשים.
ההנחה היא שה-query gates
האלה ניתנים לנו, והקושי של לבנות
אותם הוא לא הדאגה שלנו.
אתם יכולים לחשוב על
ה-query gates עצמם כעל הקלט אם תרצו, וזה לא התפקיד שלנו ליצור את הקלט, אנחנו רק מנסים
לפתור בעיה מסוימת
בהינתן הקלט. כמובן, כאשר f היא פונקציה
מביט אחד לביט אחד, יש רק ארבע בחירות אפשריות,
וזה יהיה מספיק קל
לממש כל אחת מהן, אבל באופן כללי, לפונקציות
עם הרבה ביטי קלט,
זה יכול להיות קשה מאוד לממש query gates
לפונקציות האלה.
כדי להבהיר, זה לא
אומר שהסוגיה של איך query gates ממומשים
היא לא חשובה, אלא שהיא לא נחשבת
כחלק מהעלות
של אלגוריתם שאילתות.
זה עקבי עם הרעיון שזה לא באמת
על חישוב מעשי או בנייה של מעגלים כשלעצמה,
זה על עבודה בתוך
מסגרת תיאורטית שאומרת לנו דברים מעניינים
על חישוב.
יהיה לנו עוד מה לומר על זה כשנעשה את הקפיצה מהמודל הזה למודל חישוב יותר סטנדרטי, וזה בעיקר על מה השיעור הבא,
שיעור 6, יעסוק.
עכשיו בואו נפנה את תשומת
הלב שלנו למעגלים קוונטיים.
למעגלים קוונטיים, אנחנו הולכים לשנות את
ההגדרה של query gates כדי לעשות אותם יוניטריים.
אנחנו רוצים להיות מסוגלים לעשות
שאילתות בתוך מעגלים קוונטיים ושהם יפעלו
ליניארית על מצבים קוונטיים
כדי שנוכל בפועל
לעשות שאילתות בסופרפוזיציה.
אולי נראה שאנחנו מזיזים
את קווי השער, כביכול, על ידי שינוי מה שאנחנו מתכוונים בשאילתה בהשוואה למה שראינו הרגע
למעגלים בוליאניים,
אבל יש הצדקה לזה שנדון בה ביתר
פירוט בשיעור הבא.
לעת עתה, זו סתם הגדרה.
באופן ספציפי, ההגדרה
היא כדלקמן, בהינתן כל פונקציה f באותה
צורה כמו קודם,
כלומר שהיא ממפה מחרוזות של
n ביטים למחרוזות של m ביטים, ה-query gate Uf פועל על n + m qubits
ומוגדר על ידי הפעולה
שמתוארת כאן על מצבי בסיס סטנדרטיים.
נראה איור שמייצג
את ההגדרה הזאת תוך רגע, אבל קודם, תנו לי להבהיר את הסימון
שמשתמשים בו כאן,
וכלומר שבכל פעם שאנחנו
משתמשים בסימן של ה-XOR כפעולה בין שתי
מחרוזות באותו אורך,
אנחנו מתייחסים ל-eXclusive
OR ביט-ביט, וכאן אתם יכולים לראות דוגמה.
בהגדרה, יש לנו ששני y ו-f של
x הם מחרוזות באורך m, אז המחרוזת הזאת ממש כאן
מייצגת את המחרוזת שמקבלים
על ידי XOR של שתי המחרוזות
יחד, ביט אחד בכל פעם, והנה הדיאגרמה
שמסבירה איך ה-gates האלה עובדים.
ה-n qubits העליונים מתאימים
לארגומנט של הפונקציה.
וכשהם מתחילים
במצב בסיס סטנדרטי, cat x בדיאגרמה הזאת, מצב הבסיס הסטנדרטי הזה
עובר ללא שינוי
ומהדהד כחלק מהפלט.
ה-m qubits התחתונים מתאימים לפלט
של הפונקציה f, וכשהם מתחילים בכל
מצב בסיס סטנדרטי,
cat y בדיאגרמה הזאת, מה שקורה הוא שהפלט
של הפונקציה f של x עובר XOR על המחרוזת y.
זה מה שקורה עבור
מצבי בסיס סטנדרטיים, ואם אנחנו רוצים לדעת
מה קורה באופן כללי למצבים קוונטיים אחרים, אנחנו
משתמשים בליניאריות, כמו שאנחנו תמיד עושים.
סיבה להגדיר query gates ככה שבה אנחנו מהדהדים את הקלט ומשתמשים ב-XOR ביט-ביט לפלט
היא שה-gates האלה תמיד יוניטריים לכל בחירה של הפונקציה f.
זאת, למעשה, פעולה
דטרמיניסטית.
ואם היינו מבטאים את זה כמטריצה לכל בחירה של פונקציה F, היינו מקבלים מטריצת תמורה,
כלומר כזאת עם אחד יחיד בכל שורה ובכל עמודה, וכל שאר הערכים שווים ל-0.
ומטריצות תמורה
הן תמיד יוניטריות.
למעשה, לפעולה הזאת, נקבל שהפעולה
היא ההופכי של עצמה, אז Uf דאגר שווה ל-Uf.
אם כל מה שאנחנו רוצים לעשות עם ה-gates
האלה הוא להעריך f של x לאיזושהי מחרוזת x, זה קל,
אנחנו יכולים פשוט לקבוע את y
להיות מחרוזת כל-האפסים. אז כשלוקחים את ה-eXclusive OR של y, מקבלים בסוף פשוט f של x.
כאן, דרך אגב, אתם יכולים לראות את הסימון שמשתמשים בו לציון מחרוזת כל-האפסים.
זה נראה כמו 0 בחזקת M, אבל זה לא מה שזה אומר.
זה אומר מחרוזת של אפסים
באורך שווה ל-M.
כשאנחנו מדברים על
מחרוזות בניגוד למספרים, חזקות בדרך כלל אומרות שאנחנו חוזרים על המחרוזת הזאת
מספר מסוים של פעמים,
אז זה 0 חוזר m פעמים.
זאת פשוט דרך נוחה ומדויקת לתאר את המחרוזת הזאת.
שוב, כשאנחנו
עובדים עם מודל השאילתות, אנחנו לא דואגים לגבי איך
לממש את ה-query gates האלה.
זאת אותה סוגיה
שהייתה לנו עם query gates למעגלים בוליאניים.
זה לא התפקיד שלנו להכין את הקלט, הקלט ניתן לנו בצורת
ה-query gates האלה.
אני כן אציין שאם אנחנו יודעים איך
לממש את הפונקציה f באמצעות מעגל בוליאני, אז אפשר לתרגם
את המימוש הזה
ישירות למדי למימוש מעגל
קוונטי של Uf, ונראה בדיוק איך
זה עובד בשיעור הבא.
כהערת אגב, זה למדי פשוט ליצור מעגל בוליאני
שפועל ככה, תוך שימוש ב-query gate קלאסי
בודד עבור הפונקציה f,
אבל זה שונה למדי מלהיות בעל מימוש
מעגל קוונטי של ה-gate היוניטרי הזה.
הנקודה, עם זאת, היא שעבור
אלגוריתמי שאילתות קלאסיים, שיש query gate שעובד ככה זה, למעשה, שקול
לשיש query gate
קלאסי רגיל ל-f, במובן שכל אחד מהם יכול להיות ממומש באמצעות השני.
בחלק הזה של השיעור, נדון באלגוריתם של Deutsch, שהוא אלגוריתם
שאילתות קוונטי פשוט מאוד, אבל הוא באמת פנינה.
האלגוריתם הזה בא ממאמר משנת 1985 שנכתב על ידי David Deutsch, שהיה אחד מהאנשים הראשונים שעבדו על היסודות התיאורטיים
של חישוב קוונטי.
האלגוריתם עצמו מייצג חלק קטן מאוד
מהמאמר של Deutsch משנת 1985, ולמעשה,
האלגוריתם שאנחנו עכשיו
קוראים לו האלגוריתם של Deutsch הוא בעצם גרסה משופרת של האלגוריתם שDeutsch תיאר.
הוא מספק דוגמה צנועה מאוד לאיך מחשבים קוונטיים יכולים
להציע יתרונות חישוביים, אבל צריך להתחיל איפשהו,
והוא באמת היה ניצוץ חשוב שהתחיל דברים.
האלגוריתם של Deutsch פותר בעיית שאילתות שנקראת לעתים קרובות הבעיה של Deutsch בהקשר של חישוב קוונטי,
אבל למעשה, זו לא אחרת
מאשר בעיית הזוגיות לפונקציות מביט אחד לביט אחד, שכבר דיברנו עליה.
כמו שכבר ראינו, יש ארבע פונקציות
מביט אחד לביט אחד, והן מתוארות כאן על המסך על ידי טבלאות הערכים שלהן.
הראשונה והאחרונה מהפונקציות
האלה הן קבועות, בעוד ששתי האמצעיות הן מאוזנות במובן ששני
ערכי הפלט האפשריים
מופיעים אותו מספר של פעמים.
לשתי הפונקציות הקבועות,
אנחנו רואים שהזוגיות, או במילים אחרות, ה-eXclusive OR של שני הפלטים הוא 0,
ולשתי הפונקציות המאוזנות, הזוגיות של הפלטים היא 1.
אז דרך שקולה לתאר
את בעיית הזוגיות במקרה הספציפי הזה, שבו הפונקציה f לוקחת
ביט בודד כקלט,
או במילים אחרות, הבעיה של Deutsch, היא כמו שאתם רואים כאן.
הקלט הוא פונקציה f
מביט אחד לביט אחד, והפלט הוא 0 אם f קבועה
ו-1 אם f מאוזנת.
כמו שכבר רמזתי, כל אלגוריתם שאילתות קלאסי
שפותר את הבעיה הזאת חייב לעשות לפחות שתי שאילתות ל-f.
אם אתם לומדים רק אחד
משני ערכי הפלט של f, עדיין אין לכם שום מידע בכלל על הזוגיות של שני הפלטים.
וזה, דרך אגב, נכון
גם לאלגוריתמים קלאסיים שמשתמשים באקראיות.
אקראיות יכולה לפעמים להיות מאוד שימושית לפתרון בעיות שאילתות, ונראה דוגמה
קצת מאוחר יותר בשיעור,
אבל אקראיות לא עוזרת כאן.
אז האלגוריתם שלנו מקודם הוא אופטימלי בין אלגוריתמי שאילתות קלאסיים
לבעיה של Deutsch.
עכשיו נסתכל
על האלגוריתם של Deutsch, שהוא אלגוריתם שאילתות קוונטי שפותר את הבעיה
של Deutsch באמצעות שאילתה אחת.
והנה האלגוריתם
מתואר כמעגל קוונטי.
יש לנו שני qubits
שמאותחלים כמו שאתם רואים כאן, עם העליון מאותחל ל-cat 0 והתחתון מאותחל ל-cat 1,
ונראה למה אנחנו מאתחלים את ה-qubits האלה ככה בקרוב.
אנחנו מבצעים Hadamard
gates על שני ה-qubits, מכניסים אותם ל-query gate, מבצעים עוד Hadamard
gate על ה-qubit העליון,
ואז מודדים אותו. והטענה היא שתוצאת
המדידה נותנת לנו, בוודאות, את
התשובה הנכונה לבעיה.
אז בואו ננתח את
המעגל צעד אחד בכל פעם כדי לראות בדיוק איך הוא עובד.
המצב של שני ה-qubits אחרי השכבה הראשונה של Hadamard gates הוא מכפלת הטנזור של
מצבי המינוס והפלוס.
ה-Hadamard למעלה ממפה
את מצב ה-0 למצב פלוס, וה-Hadamard למטה ממפה את מצב ה-1 למצב מינוס.
ה-qubit העליון הוא בצד ימין, וה-qubit התחתון הוא בצד שמאל, אז זה המצב שמקבלים.
חשוב מאוד שה-qubit התחתון הוא במצב מינוס, דרך אגב, זה לא היה עובד אם היינו
מאתחלים את ה-qubit התחתון
למצב 0 במקום למצב 1.
אנחנו הולכים להרחיב את המצב הזה
לחצי, כמו שאתם רואים כאן.
הסיבה לעשות את זה
לא ברורה בשלב הזה, אבל זה יהיה נוח
תוך רגע.
עכשיו, בואו נחשוב על
מצב שני ה-qubits אחרי שה-query gate מבוצע.
הדרך שבה ה-query gate
עובד היא שהוא מחשב F על מצב הבסיס
הסטנדרטי של ה-qubit העליון ועושה XOR של הערך
על ה-qubit התחתון,
וכאן אנחנו יכולים לראות את
התוצאה של לעשות את זה.
עבור האיבר הראשון, מצב הבסיס הסטנדרטי
של ה-qubit העליון הוא 0, אז f של אפס עובר XOR
על ה-qubit התחתון,
וזה עובד על ידי ליניאריות. וזה דומה עבור האיבר השני, חוץ מזה שמצב הבסיס הסטנדרטי
של ה-qubit העליון הוא 1, אז אנחנו עושים XOR של f של 1 על ה-qubit התחתון.
ובשלב הזה, אנחנו יכולים
לפשט את הביטוי הזה על ידי שימוש בנוסחה
שאתם יכולים לראות כאן למטה, שעובדת כש-a הוא 0 או 1.
ואנחנו יכולים פשוט לבדוק את זה לשני הערכים האלה בנפרד.
אם a שווה ל-0, אז
XOR עם a לא עושה כלום, ומינוס 1 בחזקת 0 הוא 1,
אז שני הצדדים שווים. ואם a שווה ל-1, מקבלים cat 1 פחות cat
0 כשעושים את ה-XOR,
שזה מינוס 1
כפול cat 0 פחות cat 1.
ואם אנחנו משתמשים בנוסחה הזאת
כדי לפשט את המצב שלנו, כאשר לוקחים a שווה
ל-f של 0 בצד שמאל ו-a שווה ל-f של 1 בצד ימין,
מקבלים את הביטוי
שאתם רואים ממש כאן.
אז כשמשווים את שני
וקטורי המצב הקוונטיים π1 ו-π2, רואים שמה שה-gate Uf עושה
זה בעצם לשים
אחד משני הערכים, f של 0 או f של 1, בחזקה
של מינוס 1,
או במילים אחרות, בפאזה
של כל איבר.
זאת הסיבה
לאתחל את ה-qubit התחתון ל-1 ולבצע Hadamard gate עליו כדי ליצור את מצב המינוס,
שמאפשר את זה לקרות.
זה נקרא תופעת ה-phase kickback, ונחזור אליה בעוד כמה רגעים כדי להסתכל עליה שוב.
זה די חשוב, ונראה את זה קורה
עוד כמה פעמים בשיעור, וגם בשיעורים מאוחרים יותר.
אנחנו יכולים עכשיו לפשט על ידי הוצאת
מצב המינוס החוצה כדי לקבל את הביטוי
שאתם רואים ממש כאן.
כהערת אגב, זה די
מעניין לשים לב שאין פה בעצם
שום שזירה.
שני המצבים האלה הם מצבי מכפלה. אז, ובכן, שזירה
היא מאוד מעניינת,
היא לא ממלאה
שום תפקיד בכלל באלגוריתם הספציפי הזה.
בואו ננקה את זה קצת כדי שיהיה לנו קצת יותר מקום.
מה שאפשר עכשיו לעשות זה
להוציא גורם של מינוס 1 בחזקת f של אפס החוצה
כדי לקבל את הביטוי של המצב
שאתם רואים ממש כאן.
תשימו לב שממש כאן, יש לנו eXclusive OR של f 0 ו-f 1 בחזקה של מינוס 1.
היינו מצפים שזה
יהיה f של 1 פחות f של 0 כי אנחנו מוציאים את הגורם של מינוס 1 בחזקת f של 0 החוצה,
אבל מקבלים את אותו
ערך אם לוקחים את ה-XOR כי אלה ביטים, והדבר היחיד שמשנה כשיש מספר שלם בחזקה
של מינוס 1
הוא האם המספר השלם הזה זוגי או אי-זוגי.
דרך אחרת לבטא את המצב
הזה היא כמו שיש לנו כאן, שבה אנחנו פשוט שוקלים
את שני המקרים האפשריים ל-XOR.
וזאת דרך נוחה
לבטא את המצב כשאנחנו שוקלים את הפעולה
של ה-Hadamard gate האחרון יחד עם המדידה.
כשמבצעים את ה-Hadamard
gate האחרון על ה-qubit העליון, מצב הפלוס
הופך למצב 0
ומצב המינוס הופך
למצב 1, שאפשר לכתוב
בצורה תמציתית יותר ככה.
ולבסוף, כשהמדידה
מבוצעת, התוצאה שמקבלים היא
אם כן ה-XOR של f 0 ו-f 1,
שזה הערך שאנחנו מחפשים, וככה האלגוריתם של Deutsch עובד.
זה די פשוט, ואם אנחנו שואלים את עצמנו מה
זה שגורם לזה לעבוד, שמאפשר לנו לחשב
את הזוגיות של שני ביטים
עם שאילתה אחת במקום שתיים, תשובה סבירה היא
שזו אינטרפרנס.
אנחנו בפועל
מחשבים f של 0 ו-f של 1 באותו זמן, כי קודם ביצענו
את ה-Hadamard gate
על ה-qubit העליון כדי לשים את הקלט ל-f
בסופרפוזיציה של 0 ו-1.
ובאמצעות ה-phase kickback יחד עם ה-Hadamard gate האחרון, אנחנו בעצם יוצרים
אינטרפרנס בונה
לתשובה הנכונה ואינטרפרנס הרסנית
לתשובה הלא נכונה.
אז אנחנו לא רואים את התשובה הלא נכונה, אנחנו רואים רק את התשובה הנכונה.
תנו לי עכשיו לומר עוד קצת על תופעת ה-phase kickback רק כדי לראות אותה מזווית
קצת אחרת.
קודם כל, בואו נשים לב
לנוסחה הפשוטה מאוד הזאת שבה b ו-c הם ערכים בינאריים שרירותיים.
בקצרה, XOR של ביט b עם הערך 1 זה אותו דבר כמו לבצע NOT gate או פעולת x על b,
וכמובן, XOR של
ביט b עם הערך 0 לא עושה לו כלום, שזה אותו דבר כמו לבצע את
פעולת הזהות עליו.
ואפשר לבטא את פעולת הזהות כ-x בחזקת 0.
אז אם מבצעים Uf gate על שני qubits במצב בסיס סטנדרטי
cat b טנזור cat a,
מקבלים את התוצאה הזאת, פשוט מההגדרה של ה-Uf gate.
ובאמצעות הנוסחה, אפשר לחילופין לכתוב את המצב הזה כמו שאתם רואים ממש כאן.
הנוסחה הזאת עובדת לכל בחירות של b, אז על ידי ליניאריות, היא עובדת
למצב שרירותי SI
במקום cat b.
ובפרט, אם אנחנו רוצים, אפשר לבחור ש-SI יהיה מצב המינוס.
ועכשיו הנה המפתח למה תופעת ה-phase
kickback קורית.
זה בגלל שפעולת ה-x
שמופעלת על מצב המינוס נותנת לנו מינוס 1 כפול מצב המינוס.
במונחים מתמטיים, אנחנו אומרים שמצב המינוס
הוא וקטור עצמי של פעולת ה-x, עם ערך עצמי השווה למינוס 1.
וקטורים עצמיים וערכים עצמיים
הם חשובים באופן קריטי באלגברה ליניארית וגם
במידע קוונטי, ויהיה לנו הרבה
יותר מה לומר עליהם
ככל שהסדרה ממשיכה.
אבל לעת עתה, כל מה שצריך
זה את הנוסחה הפשוטה הזאת.
ובאמצעותה, אפשר
לפשט את וקטור המצב שלנו.
וזה ממש שם זה בעצם תופעת ה-phase
kickback כתובה כנוסחה.
זה עובד כי מצב המינוס
הוא וקטור עצמי של פעולת ה-NOT שערך העצמי
שלו הוא מינוס אחד.
אנחנו נכליל את זה בצורה
משמעותית למדי בשיעור 7, כשנפנה לנוהל
הערכת הפאזה, שהוא מה שמניע
את האלגוריתם של Shor לפירוק לגורמים.
אפשר לראות את הנוסחה הזאת בפעולה בניתוח של האלגוריתם
של Deutsch כך.
לפני ה-query gate, המצב שלנו הוא מכפלת הטנזור של מצבי המינוס והפלוס.
לאחר מכן מפעילים את ה-query gate, ופריסה של מצב
הפלוס נותנת לנו את המצב הזה.
עכשיו מפעילים את נוסחת ה-phase kickback כדי לקבל את הביטוי הזה, ואז הניתוח
ממשיך כמו קודם.
זה אותו דבר כמו קודם, אבל כאן אנחנו פשוט שמים
דגש על ה-phase kickback כדי שנוכל לזהות אותו
וגם נוכל להיות מוכנים
לזה כשהוא יעלה שוב.
בהמשך נפנה לאלגוריתם
של Deutsch-Jozsa, שהוא הרחבה
של האלגוריתם של Deutsch שפותר למעשה כמה
בעיות שאילתות שונות.
היתרון שהאלגוריתם
של Deutsch מספק על פני אלגוריתמים קלאסיים
הוא די צנוע, שאילתה אחת מול שתיים.
האלגוריתם של Deutsch-Jozsa מגדיל את היתרון הזה במידת מה, ואסביר למה אני מתכוון
בזה כשנגיע לשם.
אפשר לראות את האלגוריתם של Deutsch-Jozsa כדרך טבעית וישירה להרחיב את האלגוריתם של Deutsch
מפונקציות מביט אחד לביט אחד לפונקציות מ-n ביטים לביט אחד, או במילים אחרות, פונקציות בצורה הזאת.
כמעגל קוונטי, האלגוריתם של Deutsch-Jozsa
נראה ככה, ואני הולך להתייחס לזה
כמעגל של Deutsch-Jozsa
רק כדי לעשות הבחנה
קטנה בין המעגל הזה לבין האלגוריתם של Deutsch-Jozsa עצמו כי יש גם צעד
עיבוד קלאסי לאחר מכן.
הרעיון הוא שאם נריץ
את המעגל הזה ואז נמדוד, נקבל איזושהי מחרוזת של n ביטים y
שאומרת לנו משהו
על הפונקציה f.
בשלב הזה, דרך אגב, עדיין לא אמרתי
מה בעיית השאילתות שאפשר לקוות לפתור
עם המעגל הזה, זה מגיע בקרוב מאוד.
אבל הנקודה היא שעל
ידי הרצה של המעגל הזה, נשיג מידע מסוים על f שעשוי פוטנציאלית לעזור
לנו לפתור בעיות שאילתות
שבהן f הוא הקלט. וכמו שאמרתי לפני רגע, אפשר בעצם להשתמש במעגל הזה
כדי לפתור כמה
בעיות שאילתות שונות.
קודם כל, בואו נסתכל
על בעיית השאילתות שידועה כבעיית Deutsch-Jozsa, שהיא הבעיה שמעגל
Deutsch-Jozsa
נועד במקור לפתור.
בעיית Deutsch-Jozsa היא הכללה של הבעיה של Deutsch, שבה המטרה היא לקבוע האם פונקציה נתונה
היא קבועה או מאוזנת.
שימו לב שזאת לא הדרך הטבעית להכליל את בעיית הזוגיות
לפונקציות בצורה הזאת.
כאן אנחנו לא מחשבים את הזוגיות, המשימה היא לפלוט 0 אם
הפונקציה f קבועה
ו-1 אם הפונקציה f מאוזנת.
הדבר הראשון שצריך לשים לב
אליו בבעיה הזאת הוא שכאשר n, מספר ביטי הקלט
לפונקציה f, הוא לפחות 2,
יש בחירות לפונקציה שאינן קבועות ואינן מאוזנות.
למשל, הנה פונקציה
מ-2 ביטים לביט אחד שהיא לא קבועה ולא מאוזנת.
היא לא קבועה כי שני הערכים הבינאריים
מופיעים בין הפלטים, והיא לא מאוזנת
כי שני ערכי הפלט
מופיעים בתדירויות שונות. 0 מופיע שלוש פעמים
ו-1 מופיע רק פעם אחת.
כדי להיות מאוזנת,
הפלטים 0 ו-1 צריכים להופיע בדיוק
אותו מספר של פעמים.
העובדה שיש פונקציות שאינן קבועות ואינן מאוזנות כאשר n הוא לפחות 2 היא בסדר, אנחנו פשוט נתייחס
לפונקציות כאלה
כקלטים של "לא אכפת". אז במילים אחרות, זאת
בעיית הבטחה.
והנה ניסוח מדויק
של הבעיה.
מובטח לנו שפונקציית הקלט f היא או קבועה או מאוזנת, והמטרה היא להבין
איזו מהן.
ואנחנו לא אחראים למה שקורה אם הקלט
לא עומד בהבטחה.
האלגוריתם של Deutsch-Jozsa,
שפותר את הבעיה הזאת, הוא קודם להריץ את מעגל Deutsch-Jozsa ואז לפלוט 0
אם המחרוזת שקיבלנו
מהמדידות היא מחרוזת כל-האפסים
ולפלוט 1 אחרת.
דרך אחרת לומר את זה היא שאנחנו מפלטים את ה-OR של
הביטים שמדדנו.
כדי לנתח את האלגוריתם של Deutsch-Jozsa, יהיה שימושי
לקחת קודם כמה רגעים לחשוב על Hadamard gates.
אפשר, כמובן, לתאר את פעולת
ה-Hadamard כמטריצה, אבל אפשר גם לתאר
אותה במונחים של הפעולה שלה
על מצבי בסיס סטנדרטיים,
כמו שאתם רואים ממש כאן.
אפשר לשלב את שתי המשוואות
האלה למשוואה אחת, שמתארת איך פעולת
Hadamard עובדת כש-a הוא כל אחד
משני הערכים הבינאריים,
ואפשר ללכת קצת יותר רחוק ולבטא את מה שמקבלים
כסכום כזה.
באמצעות הנוסחה הזאת, אפשר לבנות נוסחה שמתארת איך שכבה
של Hadamard gates עובדת, שבה מפעילים Hadamard
gate אחד על כל אחד מ-n qubits.
כאן אנחנו מתארים את הפעולה
הזאת על מצבי בסיס סטנדרטיים.
וכדי להבהיר את הסימון, כשכותבים h טנזור n ככה, שבו חלק הטנזור n הוא חזקה עילית,
מה שמתכוונים זה מכפלת
הטנזור n-כפולה של H עם עצמו, או במילים אחרות, n עותקים
של h שכולם בטנזור ביחד.
אנחנו מפעילים את הפעולה הזאת
על מצב בסיס סטנדרטי, וכאן אני עוקב אחרי
המוסכמה שQiskit משתמש בה
לאנדוקס מחרוזות בינאריות, פשוט כי זה זמן טוב
להציג את המוסכמה הזאת.
אז x0 הוא ביט, x1 הוא ביט,
וכן הלאה עם n ביטים בסך הכל, והביטים מסודרים כמו
שאתם רואים כאן על המסך.
אתם יכולים לחשוב על הדרך
הזאת לאנדוקס ביטים כמתאימה למשמעות שלהם אם אנחנו רואים מחרוזות כמייצגות
מספרים שלמים
בייצוג בינארי, למשל.
אם מפעילים Hadamard gate
על כל אחד מה-qubits האלה, אפשר לחילופין לבטא את התוצאה כמכפלת הטנזור n-כפולה
של Hadamard gate מופעל על כל qubit, ואז אפשר להפעיל את הנוסחה שלנו על כל אחד מגורמי הטנזור.
וכאן אנחנו משתמשים בשמות
y ומינוס 1 עד y1 במקום b בנוסחה,
אז אלה ערכים בינאריים. ואנחנו דואגים להשתמש בשם חדש בכל פעם שאנחנו משתמשים בנוסחה.
אם אז מרחיבים הכל באמצעות המולטיליניאריות
של מכפלות טנזור, מקבלים את הביטוי
שאתם רואים ממש כאן.
וכדי להבהיר, n הסכומים משולבים
לסכום אחד, אבל אנחנו עדיין סוכמים
על כל הערכים האפשריים
של הערכים הבינאריים הבודדים.
עכשיו בואו ננקה דברים כדי שנוכל ללכת קצת יותר רחוק.
והצעד הבא הוא
להציג פעולה חדשה על מחרוזות שנקראת המכפלה הפנימית הבינארית.
זאת פעולה על מחרוזות בינאריות באותו אורך.
ומה שהמכפלה הפנימית הבינארית של שתי מחרוזות x ו-y
באותו אורך היא, זה ה-eXclusive OR או הזוגיות
של המכפלות של הביטים הבודדים.
אפשר גם לומר שזה ה-XOR של ה-AND הלוגי של הביטים הבודדים, כי ה-AND זה אותו
דבר כמו המכפלה
לערכים בינאריים. עוד דרך לתאר
את זה היא שזה 1 או 0
תלוי האם
הסכום של מכפלות הביטים הבודדים הוא אי-זוגי או זוגי.
זה מאוד דומה למכפלה פנימית אם חושבים על מחרוזות
כוקטורים של ערכים בינאריים, אבל כאשר מחשבים מודולו-2,
או במילים אחרות, לוקחים את השארית אחרי חלוקה ב-2.
זאת לא באמת מכפלה פנימית, אז מגיע לה שם אחר.
במקרה שלפנינו, אפשר להשתמש במכפלה
הפנימית הבינארית כדי לעשות את הנוסחה שלנו לפעולת שכבה של Hadamard gates
על מצבי בסיס סטנדרטיים יותר תמציתית, והנה היא ממש כאן.
אנחנו משתמשים בעובדה
שכיוון שהסכום הזה ממש כאן מופיע בחזקה
של מינוס 1,
כל מה שמשנה הוא
האם הוא זוגי או אי-זוגי, אבל מלבד זה, זה בעצם סתם גרסה
מרוכזת של הנוסחה שלנו.
דרך אגב, המכפלה
הפנימית הבינארית היא סימטרית במובן ש-x נקודה
y ו-y נקודה x שווים,
אז אנחנו חופשיים להחליף את
הסדר מתי שזה שימושי.
ועכשיו שיש לנו את הנוסחה הזאת, יהיה די קל לנתח
את מעגל Deutsch-Jozsa.
מתחילים עם n qubits במצב 0 וה-qubit התחתון במצב 1, ומבצעים Hadamard
gates על כולם.
אז זה המצב של
ה-n + 1 qubits שמקבלים.
אנחנו מתייחסים ל-qubit
התחתון בנפרד כי זה הולך להיות נוח.
ושוב, אנחנו הולכים לראות את תופעת ה-phase
kickback קורית.
אפשר לקבל את הביטוי הזה
על ידי שימוש בנוסחה שלנו, שבה מציבים
את מחרוזת כל-האפסים במקום x ומציבים x במקום y,
ושמים לב שהמכפלה הפנימית
הבינארית של מחרוזת כל-האפסים עם כל מחרוזת היא 0.
אבל אפשר גם פשוט לחשוב על זה ישירות. אנחנו לוקחים את מכפלת
הטנזור של n מצבי פלוס, וזה מה שמקבלים,
טנזור עם מצב המינוס. ואז ה-UF gate מופעל, וכאן זה שתופעת ה-phase
kickback קורית.
הערך f של x עובר XOR
על מצב המינוס לכל x בסכום.
אז f של x נבעט לתוך הפאזה.
עכשיו מפעילים עוד
שכבה של Hadamard gates רק על n ה-qubits העליונים, והפעם, אנחנו באמת
צריכים את הנוסחה.
וכשמפעילים אותה ועושים רק קצת
פישוט, מקבלים את המצב הזה ממש כאן.
אז זה המצב הסופי שלנו ממש
לפני המדידות.
המצב נראה קצת מסובך, וקשה לפשט אותו כי אנחנו לא באמת יודעים
שום דבר על הפונקציה f.
אבל זכרו, שכל
מה שאנחנו באמת צריכים לדעת הוא האם המדידות
כולן נותנות את התוצאה 0,
כי זה מה שקובע מה התשובה שלנו לבעיה.
אם אנחנו רואים שכל
תוצאת מדידה היא 0, אנחנו מסיקים שהפונקציה קבועה.
ואם כל אחת מתוצאות
המדידה היא 1, אנחנו מסיקים שהפונקציה מאוזנת.
אז בואו נחשב את ההסתברות לקבל את מחרוזת כל-האפסים
מהמדידות.
וזה מתגלה כתוצאה האחת שהיא בעצם קלה לחישוב, כי המכפלה הפנימית
הבינארית של מחרוזת כל-האפסים
עם כל מחרוזת היא אפס. אם בוחנים את הוקטור שלנו וחושבים
על מה קורה כש-y הוא מחרוזת כל-האפסים,
מקבלים את הביטוי הזה ממש
כאן להסתברות לקבל את מחרוזת כל-האפסים
מהמדידות.
ואם שוקלים את שני המקרים האפשריים כאשר f קבועה ו-f מאוזנת, רואים שההסתברות
לקבל את מחרוזת כל-האפסים היא 1
במקרה ש-f קבועה, ואפס כאשר f מאוזנת.
כש-f קבועה, הסכום הוא או 2 בחזקת
n או מינוס 2 בחזקת n, וחלוקה ב-2 בחזקת n
ולקיחת ערך מוחלט
בריבוע נותנת 1.
וכש-f מאוזנת, הסכום שווה ל-0.
זה בגלל שנקבל
פלוס 1 ומינוס 1 מספר שווה של פעמים,
אז הם כולם מתקזזים.
אז זהו. האלגוריתם של Deutsch-Jozsa
פותר את בעיית Deutsch-Jozsa באמצעות שאילתה אחת,
ואין טעות. בהנחה שהפעולות
כולן מבוצעות בצורה מושלמת, הוא נכון בכל פעם.
אז איך זה משתווה למה
שאפשר לעשות קלאסית?
ובכן, אם אנחנו מתעקשים
על אלגוריתם דטרמיניסטי שמקבל את התשובה
הנכונה בכל פעם, אז במקרה הגרוע ביותר,
אנחנו צריכים 2 בחזקת n פחות 1 ועוד 1 שאילתות, וזה כי צריך
לשאול את הפונקציה
על יותר ממחצית הקלטים שלה כדי להיות בטוחים לגבי הפתרון.
גם אם שואלים את הפונקציה על 2 בחזקת n פחות 1
מחרוזות קלט שונות, אפשר שנראה
את אותו ערך פלט
בכל פעם, וזה יכול להיות כי
הפונקציה קבועה, או שהיא בעצם מאוזנת
ופשוט לא היה לנו מזל בצורה מדהימה כשראינו את אותו ערך
פלט בכל פעם.
אז זה יתרון עצום
של קוונטי על קלאסי, שאילתה אחת מול
מספר אקספוננציאלי של שאילתות.
עם זאת, אם משתמשים
באלגוריתם שאילתות הסתברותי ומקבלים הסתברות קטנה שהוא עונה בצורה שגויה,
אז בעצם צריך רק כמה שאילתות.
בפרט, אם בוחרים
באקראי k מחרוזות ומעריכים את הפונקציה
על המחרוזות האקראיות האלה,
אז סביר מאוד שנצליח להבין את התשובה הנכונה.
באופן ספציפי, עונים 0 או קבועה כשמקבלים את אותו ערך
פונקציה בכל פעם ו-1 או מאוזנת
מתי שרואים שני
ערכי פונקציה שונים.
אם עושים את זה, תמיד נהיה נכונים כשהפונקציה
קבועה כי, כמובן, תמיד נראה את אותו
ערך פלט במקרה הזה.
ואם f מאוזנת, סביר מאוד שנראה
שני ערכי פלט שונים.
הסיכוי שלא נראה
את שני ערכי הפלט במקרה הזה הוא אותו סיכוי כמו להטיל מטבע k פעמים
ולקבל את אותה
תוצאה בכל פעם.
אז למשל, אם קובעים
k להיות שווה ל-11, ההסתברות לקבל תשובה שגויה היא פחות מעשירית אחוז.
אז במיוחד כשמתחשבים בעובדה שמחשבים קוונטיים לעולם לא יהיו מושלמים במציאות, אנחנו לא באמת מקבלים
יתרון כל כך גדול כאן,
אבל אנחנו מתקדמים, ויש לנו יתרון ניתן לכימות של קוונטי על קלאסי שחורג מעבר לאלגוריתם של Deutsch.
אפשר גם להשתמש במעגל Deutsch-Jozsa כדי לפתור בעיית שאילתות שונה שנקראת בעיית Bernstein-Vazirani.
הנה ניסוח של הבעיה הזאת. הקלט הוא פונקציה
מ-n ביטים לביט אחד, בדיוק כמו בעיית Deutsch-Jozsa,
ושוב, זאת בעיית הבטחה.
הפעם, ההבטחה היא שקיימת מחרוזת של n ביטים s שעבורה הפונקציה f
עובדת כמו שאתם רואים ממש כאן,
שבה הפלט ניתן
על ידי המכפלה הפנימית הבינארית של הקלט עם המחרוזת s הזאת,
והמטרה היא פשוט
למצוא את המחרוזת s. אז אפשר לדמיין שהמחרוזת
s מוסתרת במובן מסוים,
אבל אפשר ללמוד עליה
על ידי ביצוע שאילתות ל-f, והמטרה שלנו היא למצוא
את המחרוזת המוסתרת הזאת.
כדי להבהיר, רוב הפונקציות
לא מקיימות את ההבטחה הזאת, אבל כרגיל, אנחנו מתעניינים רק
בפונקציות הקלט שכן.
כפי שמתברר, מעגל Deutsch-Jozsa פותר בעצם את הבעיה הזאת
ישר מהקופסה.
אם מריצים אותו עבור
פונקציה כמו שיש לנו כאן שמקיימת את ההבטחה
עבור איזושהי מחרוזת s, המדידות יחשפו את המחרוזת s
ללא צורך בעיבוד נוסף.
אז בואו נראה איך זה עובד.
כבר ניתחנו את מעגל
Deutsch-Jozsa, אז אפשר בעצם פשוט
לדלג ישר לסוף.
הנה הביטוי שהיה לנו
מקודם למצב ממש לפני המדידות, והביטוי הזה היה
תקף לכל פונקציה f.
ועכשיו, אם מציבים
את מה שמובטח לנו לגבי הפונקציה f ומפשטים,
מקבלים את מצב המינוס
ל-qubit התחתון בטנזור עם cat s ל-n ה-qubits העליונים.
ואז מקבלים s כשמודדים.
יש קצת עבודה לעשות כדי לבצע את הפישוטים
שהראיתי כאן, ולא אעבור על זה בסרטון הזה,
אבל יש יותר פירוט על זה בתוכן הספר הלימודי של הסדרה הזאת, שאפשר למצוא על ידי מעקב אחרי הקישור בתיאור של הסרטון,
או פשוט נסו את זה
בעצמכם לתרגול.
אז מה שמצאנו הוא שמעגל
Deutsch-Jozsa פותר את בעיית Bernstein-Vazirani
בשאילתה אחת.
לא קשה להראות
שכל אלגוריתם קלאסי, בין אם הוא דטרמיניסטי
או הסתברותי, צריך לפחות n שאילתות
כדי לפתור את בעיית Bernstein-Vazirani מהסיבה הפשוטה שצריך n ביטים של
מידע כדי לשחזר את s,
וכל שאילתה נותנת לנו לכל
היותר ביט אחד של מידע.
אז מקבלים עוד יתרון של אלגוריתמי שאילתות קוונטיים
על קלאסיים, שאילתה אחת לאלגוריתמים קוונטיים,
n שאילתות לאלגוריתמים קלאסיים.
כדאי לקחת רגע לדבר על הטרמינולוגיה
שמשתמשים בה בהקשר של הבעיה הזאת וקצת על ההיסטוריה.
אנשים לפעמים מתייחסים לאלגוריתם שתיארתי הרגע כאלגוריתם Bernstein-Vazirani, אבל זה באמת סתם מעגל
Deutsch-Jozsa,
וזה משהו שנאמר, למעשה,
בצורה מאוד ברורה בעבודה של Bernstein ו-Vazirani.
אז זה קצת מוזר שזה נקרא האלגוריתם של
Bernstein-Vazirani כי זה פחות או יותר אותו דבר כמו האלגוריתם של Deutsch-Jozsa
פחות העיבוד הנוסף. עם זאת, Bernstein ו-Vazirani
כן הלכו צעד נוסף.
הם הגדירו גרסה רקורסיבית
של הבעיה הזאת, שבה בעצם
צריך לפתור מופעים של בעיית Bernstein-Vazirani
כדי לפתוח מופעים חדשים של הבעיה שמסודרים
בתבנית מסובכת כמו עץ.
זאת בעיה מאולצת מאוד, אבל הנקודה היא שעל ידי
הגדרת בעיה בדרך הזאת, הם יכלו בפועל למתוח
את ההפרדה של אחד מול n שאילתות בין קוונטי לקלאסי.
ומה שהם קיבלו היא
הדוגמה הראשונה שנודעה של מה שנקרא יתרון סופר-פולינומיאלי של קוונטי על אלגוריתמים הסתברותיים.
הגרסה הרקורסיבית הזאת של בעיית
Bernstein-Vazirani גם התגלתה הרבה מאוחר יותר
כמעניינת מאוד בתורת הסיבוכיות החישובית
מסיבות שונות.
בכל מקרה, הנקודה היא ש-Bernstein
ו-Vazirani בהחלט ראויים להכרה על התרומות החשובות שלהם,
אבל באמת לא הגיוני
להתייחס לזה כאלגוריתם Bernstein-Vazirani, זה בעצם סתם
האלגוריתם של Deutsch-Jozsa.
בחלק האחרון של השיעור, נסתכל על עוד
אלגוריתם שאילתות קוונטי אחד שנקרא האלגוריתם של Simon.
תראו דמיון ברור
בין האלגוריתם הזה לאלגוריתם של Deutsch-Jozsa, אבל הוא שונה, וחשוב מכך,
הוא חושף יתרון הרבה יותר חזק של אלגוריתמי שאילתות
קוונטיים על קלאסיים.
באופן ספציפי, הוא נותן לנו
יתרון אקספוננציאלי מוכח של אלגוריתמים קוונטיים על קלאסיים, אפילו הסתברותיים.
הבעיה שהוא פותר היא קצת מלאכותית, וקשה לדמיין מצב שבו פתרון הבעיה
הזאת יהיה שימושי,
אבל היא השפיעה ישירות
על הגילוי של Peter Shor של אלגוריתם קוונטי
לפירוק מספרים שלמים לגורמים,
וזה תומך מאוד ברעיון
של מודל השאילתות כצלחת פטרי שבה רעיונות אלגוריתמיים
קוונטיים יכולים להתפתח.
בואו נתחיל עם בעיית השאילתות שהאלגוריתם של Simon פותר, שכפי שאולי ניחשתם,
נקראת הבעיה של Simon.
הנה ניסוח של הבעיה, ואנחנו הולכים לצרוך לפרק אותו כדי להבין על מה מדובר.
הדבר הראשון שצריך
לשים לב אליו הוא שהפעם, פונקציית הקלט f ממפה מחרוזות של n
ביטים למחרוזות של m ביטים
כאשר m הוא מספר שלם חיובי כלשהו שלא שווה לאחד באופן כללי.
זאת בעיית הבטחה. וכמו בעיית Bernstein-Vazirani, ההבטחה כוללת איזושהי מחרוזת s שאפשר לראות בה מחרוזת מוסתרת,
וגם כמו בעיית
Bernstein-Vazirani, המטרה היא לפלוט
את המחרוזת המוסתרת s הזאת.
ההבטחה יותר
מסובכת הפעם, אז בואו נפרק אותה
ונבין מה היא אומרת.
כדי להתחיל, בואו פשוט נקרא אותה. היא אומרת שקיימת מחרוזת s באורך שווה ל-n
כך שתנאי מסוים של "אם
ורק אם" מתקיים לכל בחירות של מחרוזות של n ביטים x ו-y.
באופן ספציפי, חייב
להיות שf של x שווה ל-f של y אם ורק אם אחת
משתי אפשרויות מתקיימת.
האפשרות הראשונה היא ש-x שווה ל-y, והאפשרות השנייה היא שעל ידי לקיחת
ה-eXclusive OR ביט-ביט של x
והמחרוזת המוסתרת s, מקבלים Y.
זו מתגלה כהבטחה
מחמירה למדי במובן שרוב
הפונקציות לא מקיימות אותה.
רק פונקציות מיוחדות מאוד
מקיימות את התנאי הזה.
עכשיו, כדי לקבל אחיזה טובה יותר בהבטחה הזאת ולכן בבעיה עצמה, נשקול שני מקרים עיקריים.
המקרה הראשון הוא ש-s
הוא מחרוזת כל-האפסים.
במקרה הזה, אפשר לפשט את ההצהרה של "אם
ורק אם" בהבטחה כי ה-eXclusive OR
ביט-ביט של כל מחרוזת x
עם מחרוזת כל-האפסים
הוא פשוט המחרוזת x.
אז התנאי מתפשט
ל-f של x שווה ל-f של y אם ורק אם x שווה ל-y.
וזאת סתם דרך אחרת לומר ש-f היא פונקציה חד-חד-ערכית.
במילים אחרות, המחרוזת f של x חייבת להיות ייחודית
לכל מחרוזת x אפשרית.
אז אם f היא פונקציה חד-חד-ערכית, אז ההבטחה אכן מתקיימת, ספציפית עבור s שהוא
מחרוזת כל-האפסים,
ובמקרה הזה, זה
הפלט הנכון.
המקרה השני הוא ש-s
הוא לא מחרוזת כל-האפסים, ומה שזה גורר הוא שהפונקציה f חייבת להיות שתיים-לאחד.
אז לכל מחרוזת קלט x, יש בדיוק מחרוזת אחת אחרת ש-f ממפה לאותה
מחרוזת ש-x ממופה אליה,
ויתר על כן, המחרוזת האחרת
חייבת להיות המחרוזת שמקבלים על ידי לקיחת
ה-eXclusive OR ביט-ביט של x עם s.
דרך אחרת לומר את זה
היא שלכל מחרוזת של n ביטים x יש שותף, והשותף הזה הוא המחרוזת שמקבלים
על ידי לקיחת ה-eXclusive OR ביט-ביט עם s.
כל שני שותפים חייבים לתת
לנו את אותה מחרוזת פלט אם מכניסים אותם ל-f, ואין מחרוזות אחרות שמותר להן לתת לנו
את אותה מחרוזת פלט.
אז אלה בהכרח מחרוזות שונות שהשותפים מייצרים.
הנה דוגמה לפונקציה כזאת שמתוארת על ידי טבלת הערכים שלה.
אז זאת פונקציה
מ-3 ביטים ל-5 ביטים.
אם מסתכלים על טבלת
הערכים הזאת לזמן מה, מוצאים שההבטחה
מתקיימת עבור המחרוזת 011.
000 ו-011 הם שותפים. XOR של כל אחד מהם
ב-s נותן את השני,
והם לוקחים את אותו ערך פלט, שהוא 10011 במקרה הספציפי הזה, ואין מחרוזות אחרות שמייצרות
את אותה מחרוזת פלט.
001 ו-010 הם שותפים כי XOR של כל
אחד ב-s נותן את השני, והם מייצרים את אותו ערך פלט,
שגם הוא לא מיוצר
על ידי שום מחרוזת אחרת.
והמצב דומה
ל-100 ו-111 וגם ל-101 ו-110.
אז אם הקלט לבעיה
הוא הפונקציה הזאת, התשובה הנכונה היא המחרוזת 011.
כמו שאמרתי קודם, רוב הפונקציות לא מקיימות את ההבטחה הזאת, זה תנאי מאוד ספציפי.
כדאי גם לציין שאם
ההבטחה מתקיימת, היא יכולה להתקיים רק עבור מחרוזת s אחת.
אז תמיד יש רק תשובה
נכונה אחת לבעיה הזאת.
אז זאת הבעיה של Simon. כמו שאמרתי, קשה לדמיין מצב מעשי שבו תרצו לפתור את הבעיה הזאת,
אבל זאת לא הנקודה. הנקודה היא לנסות להבין במה מחשבים קוונטיים טובים, ומתגלה שהם עדיפים בהרבה
על אלגוריתמים קלאסיים
בפתרון הבעיה הספציפית הזאת.
עכשיו בואו נסתכל
על האלגוריתם של Simon, שפותר את הבעיה של Simon.
האלגוריתם מורכב מהרצה
של המעגל הקוונטי שאתם רואים כאן מספר פעמים, ואחר כך צעד
עיבוד קלאסי,
ונהיה יותר ספציפיים לגבי מה מספר
פעמים אומר קצת מאוחר יותר.
המעגל נראה מאוד דומה
למעגל Deutsch-Jozsa, הפעם כי הפונקציה
f ממפה n ביטים ל-m ביטים,
ה-query gate שונה. במקום סתם qubit
בודד למטה, עכשיו יש לנו m qubits למטה
ו-n למעלה כמו קודם.
הבדל מרכזי הוא שאנחנו
לא מגדירים מצב מינוס או מספר מצבי מינוס למטה.
ה-qubits התחתונים האלה כולם
מאותחלים למצב 0, והמצבים האלה הולכים ישר
לתוך ה-query gate.
אז לא יהיה phase kickback מעורב באלגוריתם הזה, זה פשוט לא ככה האלגוריתם הזה עובד.
חוץ מההבדלים
שהזכרתי הרגע, הוא נראה מאוד דומה
למעגל Deutsch-Jozsa.
מפעילים שכבה של Hadamard gates, ואז מפעילים query gate פעם אחת, ואז מפעילים עוד
שכבה של Hadamard gates
ואחר כך מדידות בסיס סטנדרטי של n ה-qubits העליונים.
הרעיון הוא שכל פעם שמריצים
את המעגל הזה ומודדים, נקבל איזושהי מחרוזת y שמספרת לנו משהו
על המחרוזת המוסתרת s
בבעיה של Simon. ועל ידי הרצת המעגל
מספר פעמים באופן עצמאי, נאסוף מספיק
ראיות סטטיסטיות על s
כדי שנוכל להבין מה
הוא ברמת ביטחון גבוהה.
עכשיו בואו ננתח את המעגל
הקוונטי של האלגוריתם של Simon כדי לראות מה הוא עושה.
המצב אחרי השכבה הראשונה
של Hadamard gates נראה ככה, בדומה למה שהיה לנו
עבור האלגוריתם של Deutsch-Jozsa.
חוץ מזה שהפעם, m ה-qubits התחתונים כולם במצב 0
ולא במצבי מינוס.
אחרי שה-query gate מבוצע, רואים שהערך f של x נכתב על
m ה-qubits התחתונים או השמאליים ביותר,
וזה כי f של x עבר XOR על מחרוזת כל-האפסים.
אז שוב, אין phase kickback קורה באלגוריתם הזה.
לאחר מכן מבצעים את השכבה השנייה
של Hadamard gates.
ובאמצעות אותה נוסחה כמו קודם לפעולה של שכבת
Hadamard gates על מצב בסיס
סטנדרטי, cat x במקרה הזה,
כמו שהיה בנוסחה המקורית, מקבלים את המצב הזה ממש כאן, שבו הפעולה של ה-Hadamard gates
הפכה ליותר נראית לעין. אבל אם רוצים, אפשר גם לכתוב את המצב
בצורה יותר מרוכזת כמו שיש לנו ממש כאן.
בשלב הזה, מודדים את n ה-qubits העליונים כדי לקבל מחרוזת כלשהי של n ביטים y, ואנחנו רק צריכים להבין
מה ההסתברויות
למחרוזות השונות. וזה יעזור לנו להבין
איזה מידע מקבלים מהמחרוזת y הזאת על המחרוזת s
שמוסתרת בתוך הפונקציה f.
אנחנו הולכים לצרוך
עוד מקום לזה, ואנחנו באמת לא צריכים
את דיאגרמת המעגל יותר, אז בואו ניפטר ממנה וניתן לעצמנו עוד
מקום לניתוח.
הנה המצב ממש
לפני המדידות, שהן מדידות בסיס סטנדרטי של n ה-qubits העליונים או הימניים ביותר.
אז המדידה
מתאימה ל-cat השני.
בואו נסמן ב-p של y, את ההסתברות שהמדידות נותנות לנו את המחרוזת y עבור כל y אפשרי.
ואם עוקבים אחרי הכללים משיעור 2, מקבלים שכל אחת מההסתברויות האלה היא הנורמה האוקלידית בריבוע של כל וקטור שבטנזור
עם מצב הבסיס הסטנדרטי,
שמתאים ל-y בוקטור
המצב הקוונטי שלנו.
זה נותן לנו את הביטוי הזה ממש כאן.
עכשיו, כדי לקבל אחיזה טובה
יותר בהסתברויות האלה, אנחנו הולכים
להשתמש בסימון מסוים, ואולי אתם כבר
מכירים את הסימון הזה
כי הוא די נפוץ במתמטיקה.
קודם כל, כשמתייחסים
לטווח של הפונקציה f, פשוט מתכוונים לקבוצה של כל המחרוזות שיכולות לצאת מהפונקציה הזאת.
אז זאת קבוצת כל f של x לכל הבחירות
האפשריות של מחרוזת קלט x.
שנית, אנחנו הולכים להשתמש בסימון הזה שאתם רואים ממש כאן כדי לציין את קבוצת כל מחרוזות הקלט x
ש-f ממפה למחרוזת נתונה z, לכל בחירה של
z שנרצה לשקול.
זה קצת נראה כמו
ההופכי של הפונקציה f, אבל זה לא באמת ההופכי כי f היא לא בהכרח הפיכה.
אנחנו גם רואים שיש
לנו קבוצה כארגומנט בצד שמאל, ובמקרה הזה, זאת הקבוצה שמכילה
רק מחרוזת בודדת z,
וזה הרמז שצריך כדי לזהות שאנחנו לא מדברים על
ההופכי של הפונקציה f, זה נקרא תמונה קדומה.
אפשר להגדיר את התמונה
הקדומה באופן כללי יותר לכל קבוצה שניתנת כארגומנט, לא רק לקבוצה שמכילה
איבר בודד,
אבל זה כל מה שנצטרך. זה לא הסימון
הכי טוב בעולם כי קל
לבלבל אותו עם ההופכי,
אבל הוא מספיק ברור
והוא בשימוש רחב, אז נלך עם זה.
ועכשיו אם משתמשים בסימון הזה, אפשר לכתוב מחדש את הוקטור שאנחנו לוקחים
את הנורמה האוקלידית בריבוע שלו כדי לקבל את ההסתברות
למדוד כל מחרוזת y.
אנחנו עושים את זה כי צריך לראות
מה המקדמים לכל מצב בסיס סטנדרטי בנפרד, וזה לא ברור מהביטוי
הזה ממש כאן,
כי, באופן כללי, ייתכן
שיש מספר בחירות של x שנותנות לנו את אותה מחרוזת f של x.
במהות, כל מה שאנחנו עושים
הוא פיצול של הסכום על x על ידי קודם כל סכימה על כל
z בטווח של f,
ואז בתוך הסכום הזה, סכימה על כל x בתמונה הקדומה של z, או ליתר דיוק,
התמונה הקדומה של הקבוצה
שמכילה את המחרוזת z.
זה מאפשר לנו להחליף את f של x ב-z בתוך ה-cat ממש כאן.
והסכום על כל המחרוזות
השונות x ש-f ממפה לכל z נאספים למקדם
של כל cat.
אנחנו בעצם שמים מחרוזות לתוך סלים, סוכמים על הסלים, ואז סוכמים על
המחרוזות בכל סל,
אבל זה שקול לפשוט
לסכום על כל המחרוזות.
אז אנחנו אכן מקבלים ביטוי שהוא שקול לזה
שהתחלנו איתו,
ועכשיו אפשר לחשב את
הנורמה האוקלידית בריבוע.
זה פשוט סכום הריבועים של הערכים המוחלטים
של המקדמים, ואז מקבלים את הביטוי הזה ממש כאן
להסתברויות שלנו.
כמובן, תנו לעצמכם
זמן לאמת את זה, אם בוחרים לעשות את זה, זה לוקח זמן להתרגל לכל זה
ולהיות מסוגלים לבצע
את החישובים האלה, וככל שתתרגלו יותר, ככה זה יהפוך לקל יותר.
עד עכשיו, לא השתמשנו
בעצם בהבטחה בבעיה של Simon בכלל.
הניתוח שלנו של ההסתברויות האלה בעצם עובד לכל פונקציה f, אבל עכשיו הגיע הזמן לחשוב על הבעיה
של Simon באופן ספציפי.
אנחנו הולכים לפרק דברים לאותם שני מקרים
שהיו לנו קודם.
המקרה הראשון הוא ש-s
הוא מחרוזת כל-האפסים, והמקרה השני הוא
ש-s אינו מחרוזת כל-האפסים.
במקרה הראשון, ש-s
הוא מחרוזת כל-האפסים, הדברים די פשוטים.
במקרה הזה, כמו שראינו קודם, יש לנו ש-f היא פונקציה חד-חד-ערכית, אז יש מחרוזת x אחת
שממופה לכל אחת
מהמחרוזות z בטווח של f.
זה הופך את הערך המוחלט בריבוע של הסכום על המחרוזות האלה לשווה ל-1 כי יש רק
איבר אחד בסכום,
הוא או פלוס 1 או מינוס 1, אבל לא משנה מה כי אנחנו לוקחים את הערך
המוחלט בריבוע, ואז מקבלים אחד.
יש 2 בחזקת n
איברים בטווח של f, ואנחנו יודעים את זה כי f היא חד-חד-ערכית, אז יש מחרוזת אחת בטווח
לכל מחרוזת קלט.
ואם מחשבים את כל הביטוי, מוצאים שכל מחרוזת y מופיעה בהסתברות
אחד חלקי 2 בחזקת n.
אז במילים אחרות,
המדידות נותנות לנו מחרוזת y שנבחרת באופן אחיד באקראי.
זה אולי לא נשמע כל כך שימושי, אבל אנחנו, למעשה, נוכל
להבחין בין ההתנהגות הזאת לבין ההתנהגות שמקבלים במקרה
ש-s אינו מחרוזת כל-האפסים, ונראה איך זה הולך בקרוב.
לעת עתה, פשוט נשים לב שאם
f מקיימת את ההבטחה בבעיה של Simon במקרה ש-s הוא מחרוזת כל-האפסים,
אז תוצאת המדידות היא מחרוזת אקראית אחידה.
עכשיו בואו נעבור למקרה השני, שהוא שההבטחה
מתקיימת עבור מחרוזת s שאינה מחרוזת כל-האפסים.
במקרה הזה, כמו שדיברנו קודם, לכל מחרוזת z בטווח של f יש בדיוק שתי מחרוזות שממופות אליה,
כי לכל מחרוזת יש שותף, וכל זוג שותפים
ממופה לאיזושהי מחרוזת ייחודית, ובאופן ספציפי, השותף של כל מחרוזת
הוא המחרוזת שמקבלים על ידי XOR עם s.
אז אם בוחרים מחרוזת
כלשהי z בטווח של f, ונותנים את השם w לאחת
מהמחרוזות ש-f ממפה ל-z,
אז ה-XOR של w עם s הוא
המחרוזת השנייה שממופה ל-z.
אם מסתכלים רק על האיבר האחד בסכום שלנו שמתאים לכל מחרוזת z בטווח שיש לנו בראש,
רואים שאפשר
לכתוב אותו יותר במפורש כמו שיש לנו ממש כאן.
יש לנו שתי מחרוזות בתמונה הקדומה של z, w ו-w XOR עם s.
אז אפשר לכתוב את הסכום
כמו שרואים על המסך, ועכשיו מה שאפשר לעשות הוא להוציא גורם של
מינוס 1 בחזקת w נקודה y.
הגורם הזה הולך להיות
או פלוס 1 או מינוס 1, אז הוא נעלם כשלוקחים
את הערך המוחלט,
ומה שנשאר הוא
הביטוי הזה ממש כאן.
הפרטים לא כולם מוצגים כאן, וזה לא בהכרח
ברור שזה עובד ככה, אבל אפשר לבדוק ששני
הביטויים האלה שווים
על ידי חזרה להגדרה
של המכפלה הפנימית הבינארית ולחשוב על מה קורה כשהדברים האלה
בחזקה של מינוס 1,
לא שונה ממה שהיה לנו
עבור בעיית Bernstein-Vazirani.
לבסוף, אפשר לפרק את הביטוי
הזה לשני מקרים.
הוא 4 כאשר המכפלה הפנימית
הבינארית של s ו-y היא 0, והוא 0 כאשר המכפלה
הפנימית הבינארית של s ו-y היא 1.
שימו לב בפרט שאין
תלות בכלל כאן ב-w או z, זה תלוי רק ב-s וב-y.
הסיבה שזה קורה היא
בגלל האופי המאוד ספציפי והמיוחד של ההבטחה.
במהות, זו הסיבה שההבטחה נוסחה בדרך הזאת, כדי שהכל יסתדר ככה.
שוב, לכל מחרוזת יש שותף, שמקבלים על ידי XOR עם
המחרוזת המוסתרת s הזאת,
וזה מה שגורם לכל זה לקרות.
עכשיו אפשר לחזור לביטוי
של ההסתברויות ולהציב דברים.
כש-s אינו מחרוזת כל-האפסים, יש 2 בחזקת n פחות 1
איברים בטווח של f,
שזה חצי ממספר
מחרוזות הקלט, והצבת
הערכים שחישבנו הרגע נותנת את הנוסחה הזאת ממש כאן.
אז הפעם, y היא לא
מחרוזת אקראית לחלוטין, אלא y אחידה על בדיוק חצי ממחרוזות ה-n ביטים,
ובאופן ספציפי, היא
אחידה על אותן מחרוזות שהמכפלה הפנימית
הבינארית שלהן עם s שווה ל-0.
עכשיו שאנחנו יודעים איך המעגל
של האלגוריתם של Simon עובד ובאופן ספציפי מה
ההסתברויות לתוצאות המדידה השונות,
נשאר להסביר איך זה עוזר לנו לפתור את הבעיה של Simon.
בסיכום מה שלמדנו, אם זה המצב שהפונקציה f מקיימת את ההבטחה בבעיה של Simon,
כאשר המחרוזת המוסתרת s
היא מחרוזת כל-האפסים, מקבלים מחרוזת אקראית
לחלוטין מהמדידות,
כאשר כל מחרוזת של n ביטים
y שווה בסבירות.
אם מצד שני, הפונקציה f מקיימת את ההבטחה עבור מחרוזת s אחרת, כזאת שלא שווה
למחרוזת כל-האפסים,
אז מקבלים מחרוזת אקראית y שהמכפלה הפנימית
הבינארית שלה שווה ל-0 עם s, ובין כל המחרוזות האלה,
כל y שווה בסבירות.
אבל לעולם לא נקבל מחרוזת y שהמכפלה הפנימית
הבינארית שלה שווה ל-1 עם s.
השאלה הופכת ל"האם זה מספיק מידע
כדי לקבוע את s?" והתשובה, כמו שכבר
רמזתי, היא כן,
בתנאי שמריצים
את המעגל מספיק פעמים.
באופן ספציפי, נניח
שמריצים את המעגל k פעמים, כאשר K שווה ל-n ועוד r,
כאשר r הוא מספר כלשהו שהולך לשלוט
בסבירות שנשחזר את s.
רק כדוגמה, אם
בוחרים r להיות 10, נצליח בהסתברות
גדולה מ-99.9%,
אז לא צריך ש-r יהיה כל כך גדול.
באופן כללי, ההסתברות לכישלון היא פחות מההסתברות
להטיל מטבע הוגן r פעמים ולקבל עץ בכל פעם.
אז אם 99.9% לא מספיק
טוב, אז קחו r להיות 20, והסיכוי לכישלון הוא
פחות מאחד למיליון,
או בחרו כל r
שנוח לכם. אי אפשר להבטיח פתרון נכון, אבל אפשר להפוך
את ההסתברות לטעות לזניחה
לכל דבר ועניין.
כאן אנחנו קוראים למחרוזות
האלה y1 עד yk, כאשר אנחנו משתמשים בחזקות עיליות כדי לעזור לנו לקרוא שמות למחרוזות האלה,
רק כדי שנוכל לשמור על כתבים תחתונים כדי להתייחס לביטים
הבודדים של המחרוזות האלה.
אז אלה לא חזקות
או משהו כזה, אלה סתם השמות שאנחנו נותנים ל-k המחרוזות האלה.
לכל אחת אורך n כי קיבלנו אותן
מהרצת המעגל של האלגוריתם של Simon.
אז אפשר לכתוב את
הביטים הבודדים של k המחרוזות האלה כמו שרואים ממש כאן.
מה שעושים עכשיו הוא ליצור מטריצה m, שבה כל ערך במטריצה הזאת הוא ביט, ומקבלים את הביטים האלה מהמחרוזות
שמדדנו הרגע, בדיוק כמו שמוצג ממש כאן.
אז למטריצה הזאת יש k שורות ו-n עמודות, והערכים שלה כולם ערכים בינאריים.
עכשיו, אנחנו לא יודעים מה s. זה מה שאנחנו מנסים למצוא, אבל רק דמיינו לרגע
שכן ידענו את s,
ויצרנו וקטור עמודה
מהביטים של s, בדיוק כמו שמוצג ממש כאן.
אם היינו מכפילים את הוקטור הזה ב-m ואז לוקחים את התוצאה מודולו-2, או דרך אחרת לומר את זה
היא שמחליפים חיבור
ב-eXclusive OR, אז בהכרח
נקבל את וקטור כל-האפסים.
זה כי כל אחד מהערכים
בוקטור התוצאה הזה הוא לא אחר מאשר המכפלה
הפנימית הבינארית של s
עם אחת השורות של m.
אם S הוא במקרה מחרוזת כל-האפסים, תמיד נקבל את וקטור האפס מהמכפלה הפנימית הבינארית.
ואם s אינו מחרוזת כל-האפסים, נקבל את זה ממה שאנחנו
יודעים על ההסתברויות למחרוזות y1 עד yk להופיע.
בפרט, המכפלה
הפנימית הבינארית עם s היא תמיד אפס לכל המחרוזות האלה.
דרך פשוטה לומר את זה היא שהוקטור הזה
שנוצר מהביטים של s תמיד נמצא במרחב
האפס של המטריצה m,
בהנחה שאנחנו עושים את כל
החשבון מודולו-2, אבל כמובן, אנחנו לא יודעים מה s,
אנחנו מנסים למצוא את s.
אבל מה שאפשר לעשות הוא לחשב את
מרחב האפס של המטריצה m הזאת, שוב, מודולו-2.
באופן ספציפי, אפשר לעשות את זה באמצעות טכניקת
האלימינציה הגאוסיאנית, שהיא הנוהל שלעתים קרובות מלמדים
בקורסי מבוא לאלגברה ליניארית.
היא עובדת מצוין כשעושים את כל החשבון מודולו-2, ואפשר לבצע אותה
ביעילות רבה עם מחשב.
ואם מחשבים את מרחב האפס של m, בהינתן הדרך הספציפית שבה k המחרוזות האלה
נבחרו באקראי,
נוכל לשחזר את s בהסתברות גדולה מ-1
פחות 2 בחזקת מינוס r.
ליתר דיוק, מה שנראה בהסתברות גדולה מ-1
פחות 2 בחזקת מינוס r הוא שמרחב האפס
כולל את וקטור כל-האפסים,
כמו שזה תמיד המצב לכל מטריצה, וגם את הוקטור שמתאים ל-s, בין אם הוא וקטור כל-האפסים או לא.
והכי חשוב, אף וקטורים אחרים לא
יופיעו במרחב האפס.
בעצם לא קשה להוכיח את זה, למרות שלא אעבור על זה בפירוט.
הרעיון הוא שאם
יש לנו מחרוזת אחרת שהיא לא וקטור
כל-האפסים והיא לא s, אז כל אחת מהמחרוזות
האקראיות, y1 עד yk,
בעצם הולכת להוציא
אותה ממרחב האפס בהסתברות של חצי.
אז אחרי k ניסיונות, בכלל לא
סביר שהיא תישרוד, ולמעשה, אף אחת מהמחרוזות
שלא שייכות
לא סבירה לשרוד. ועובדה פשוטה מאוד
מתורת ההסתברות, שנקראת חסם האיחוד, יכולה
לשמש כדי להוכיח את זה.
לא הסברתי את כל
הפרטים כאן, אבל בתקווה, אתם מבינים את הרעיון שעל ידי חישוב מרחב
האפס מודולו-2 של המטריצה m הזאת,
סביר מאוד שנשחזר את s, וככה האלגוריתם של Simon
פותר את הבעיה של Simon.
יש רק עוד דבר אחד
לומר על הבעיה של Simon, והוא נוגע לקושי
הקלאסי של הבעיה הזאת,
כלומר, כמה שאילתות אלגוריתם שאילתות קלאסי צריך כדי לפתור את הבעיה של Simon?
התשובה היא, הרבה, באופן כללי.
יש הצהרות מדויקות שונות
שאפשר לעשות לגבי הקושי הקלאסי
של הבעיה הזאת, והנה רק אחת מהן.
אם יש לנו אלגוריתם שאילתות
הסתברותי כלשהו והאלגוריתם הזה עושה פחות מ-2 בחזקת n חלקי 2
פחות 1, פחות 1 שאילתות,
אז זה מספר שאילתות
שהוא אקספוננציאלי ב-n, אז האלגוריתם הזה ייכשל
בפתרון הבעיה של Simon,
בהסתברות של לפחות חצי.
לפעמים, להוכיח
תוצאות חוסר-אפשרות כאלה יכול להיות מאוד מאתגר, אבל את זה לא קשה מדי להוכיח
דרך ניתוח הסתברותי
אלמנטרי.
אני לא אעשה את זה בשיעור הוידאו הזה, ובמקום אתמקד
באינטואיציה מאחורי זה.
אנחנו מנסים למצוא את המחרוזת המוסתרת s, אבל כל עוד לא שואלים את הפונקציה על שתי מחרוזות שיש להן
אותו ערך פלט,
נקבל מידע מאוד
מוגבל על s.
בעצם, כל מה שלומדים הוא
שהמחרוזת המוסתרת s היא לא ה-eXclusive OR של כל שתי
מחרוזות שונות ששאלנו,
ואם שואלים את הפונקציה בפחות ממספר השאילתות הזה, עדיין יהיו הרבה בחירות של s
שלא נשללו.
זו לא הוכחה פורמלית,
אבל זה הרעיון הבסיסי.
אז לסיכום, האלגוריתם של Simon מספק לנו יתרון מרשים של קוונטי על קלאסי
בתוך מודל השאילתות.
בפרט, האלגוריתם של Simon
פותר את הבעיה של Simon עם מספר שאילתות שהוא ליניארי במספר ביטי
הקלט n לפונקציה שלנו,
בעוד שכל אלגוריתם קלאסי,
גם אם הוא הסתברותי, צריך לעשות מספר
שאילתות שהוא אקספוננציאלי ב-n
כדי לפתור את הבעיה של Simon עם הסתברות סבירה להצלחה.
זה נכון שהבעיה של Simon היא בעיה קצת מלאכותית שככל הנראה אף אחד
לא באמת רוצה לפתור,
אבל זה משני. לפעמים רעיונות צריכים להתפתח לפני שמיישמים אותם בפרקטיקה.
ואכן, Peter Shor הצהיר בבירור שזה היה האלגוריתם של Simon שהשפיע על האלגוריתם הקוונטי המפורסם שלו
לפירוק מספרים שלמים לגורמים, שנראה בעוד כמה שיעורים.
וזה סוף שיעור 5.
בשיעור הזה, הסתכלנו על מודל
השאילתות של חישוב, וראינו רצף של דוגמאות
של אלגוריתמים קוונטיים
שמציגים יתרונות על אלגוריתמים קלאסיים
בתוך המודל הזה.
יש, למעשה, הרבה יותר
שידוע על מודל השאילתות ואלגוריתמים קוונטיים לבעיות אחרות
שלא דנתי בהן.
אז אם אתם מוצאים
את המודל הזה מעניין, יש עוד הרבה
מה ללמוד עליו.
הצעד הבא שלנו יהיה להתרחק
ממודל השאילתות ולכיוון מודל חישוב
שהוא יותר מייצג
את סוגי הבעיות שאנחנו עשויים לקוות לפתור בפרקטיקה.
אני מקווה שתצטרפו אליי לשיעור 6, שבו נתמקד בעיקר
בהנחת יסודות לחקר אלגוריתמים קוונטיים.
ומשם, נמשיך לכמה
אלגוריתמים קוונטיים ספציפיים, כולל האלגוריתם של Shor
לפירוק מספרים שלמים לגורמים
בשיעורים הבאים. להתראות עד אז!